foreign
[Music]
hey what's going on everybody I keep
forgetting how short that intro is that
I'm sitting there going because it goes
dark and then I was like oh oh it's all
psychedelic
I don't know what I'm doing after time
so obviously today is another Friday I'm
going to Usher you into the weekend
so many people are dirty when I say it
what's that that always sounds dirty
when you say it what it has I don't know
I don't know why the Usher you into the
weekend yeah how's that dirty I don't
know you got some [__] dirty [__] on
your mind
but uh we're probably we're not gonna go
out tonight
uh we're gonna go out next week
uh soap's coming should be over here
Thursday
what day is she coming Thursday well no
I mean the date 27th
okay
this coming Thursday no 27 I think
what's today oh okay so today's the 17th
right all right so so no 20 yes so we
should probably like save up because
next weekend we wanted to take her to
mannequins and to Barbarella yeah so I'm
gonna be really tired but it's like well
as long as I know ahead of time and I
can like mentally prepare myself
it was a Friday I'm driving
just um
probably won't be able to do we probably
won't be able to do the show on a Friday
or we can't well we'll probably do the
show on Saturday next week we'll just do
it maybe we'll do it probably like a
little bit earlier like maybe at six
o'clock because that way you don't have
you don't have to come home get ready
then do the show and then go out and
then go out so it doesn't make sense for
that it makes more sense to do it on
Saturday yeah
so that yeah so the Side Tracks next
week will be on Saturday right
um yeah so everybody's saying happy
Friday Tom and Jenny Zach says you know
whenever someone someone calls you all
the time and Jenny I'm imagining you
it's cartoony versions of yourselves but
looking like Tom and Jerry yeah
everybody said that yeah
I'm sorry
Graham has a bag of frozen peas in his
lap
what's he eating okay
all right did you have something happen
no vasectomy he got his oh that's right
remember he said about that yeah because
I was yeah I was remembering that so
it's like frozen peas out of your crotch
you got to get that done if you had that
done then that saves you a lot of money
on HRT because you don't have to worry
about taking HCG to to maintain your
fertility because you're not trying to
you're shooting blanks now see miles
just might as well just go on test be a
lot cheaper for you because test would
just be a standalone
just hit me up I'll [__] show you
where I get my [__] I'll show you the
site it's cheaper just get yourself
[__] just jacked Jack yourself up on
that [__] testosterone
make your wife forget regret it make
your way why would you want to do that
what's that knob just [__] with you uh
from this day forward it's no additional
little granters will ever walk the earth
you've already got kids though right so
so it's okay
Zach says he would make a better James
Bond villain
Kate Blanchette uh Alice Creech or
Isabel Uber because I'm basically
casting my fan fiction at this point
Cate Blanchette I feel like she played
um a villain in that terrible Indiana
Jones movie and for some reason like as
soon as you brought her up as a bond
villain that was the first thing that I
thought of oh she played the psychic
right the Communist psychic the Russian
that was like the only interesting
character in the movie yeah yeah so I
was like I don't know I just imagined
that I don't know I kind of feel like
Isabell repair would probably be good I
always really really liked her I haven't
seen her in anything in a really long
time but I saw a bunch of her movies
like back in the 90s in 2000. they got a
new Indiana Jones and they've reshoted
about five times [__] evidently it's
been Disney's like most expensive
failure of all times like nobody nobody
likes it it's [__] stupid uh Indiana
Jones in a time machine type Time Warp
where he's
um a lot he's he's coming face to face
with his younger self in another
timeline they've been talking about
doing that for a long time yeah so it's
supposed to look pretty good the CG but
the story is supposed to be [__]
terrible uh so they keep having to
reshoot it over and over again it's
gonna suck I mean
that last hit he had a joke there just
should be those three movies
and Indiana Jones three what was the
Last Crusade wasn't that great
that was that was one with his dad right
yeah Sean Connery yeah it has some
creepy [__] in there I liked that one
better the second time I watched it I
didn't love it the first time I saw it
but when I saw it again I was like oh
and I think you appreciate that one more
when you're older yeah it is it is it is
better than [__] Temple of Doom uh I
remember liking Temple of Doom as a kid
until I saw re-watched it recently
and it's very screamy that girl screams
and it [__] every time honestly I
think that's the only thing that ruins
it is getting captcha yeah like if
they'd cast somebody else I think that
would have been a kraken movie yeah
because everything else about it is good
because that when I was a kid that was
kind of like my favorite one because it
was like a horror movie and I was into
it yeah yeah they did [__] in that they
would never do today
pulling that guy's heart out and set it
on fire and lowering people into lava
that's back when they did cool [__]
well for being a movie aimed at kids
kind of I don't know if it was
necessarily in the kids it was aimed at
a general
yeah
well there was a lot of cool PG movies
back in those days
they weren't they weren't having to
worry about a sensitive audience they
just would just tell the [__] story
um as long as it didn't have nudity or
cussing in it it was [__] PG didn't
really matter what happened the violence
or anything they didn't really care but
in some but it couldn't show Gore I well
the weird thing about it is that I
always kind of feel like American movies
are really really strange in that way
it's like you can get away with a lot
more like Gore
but you show a tit and everybody like
flips out yeah like and it's been like
that I was like that's really stupid
although some of the movies didn't make
any goddamn sense about that like Blue
Lagoon
it was not a [__] not only to have
tits it was underage tits and that one I
think wasn't she underage yeah in Blue
Lagoon what was her name Brooke Shields
all right and they played that on HBO
yeah I thought I'd probably like they
play it a million [__] times you saw
it a million [__] times I kind of
liked the movie I remember liking it as
a kid
yeah I don't remember much about it but
I remember being okay I remember the uh
they got out with the the uh the ship
sank and they were on a Lifeboat with an
old dude who was eating what was it
[__] he pulled uh chewing tobacco out
of the [__]
was it chewing tobacco is he chewing and
he was Row in the boat it's been like a
million years since I don't remember
anything to do with chewing tobacco yeah
he got him to the island he got him to
the island and I think he drank himself
to death
on the island and and they were left
without supervision
because I think he was up you don't
remember that part huh I told you I
don't remember any of it damn really
good to see it again I mean I was a kid
when I saw it and I was just kind of
like oh okay that was diverting and that
was like about it yeah
turned out that they weren't alone on
the island they had people out there uh
uh like animals
see I don't remember that anyway I don't
remember a single [__] thing about
that movie
they got off the island eventually but
hey spoiler alert yeah no I don't
remember a single [__] thing about
that movie yeah I think a ship came and
eventually rescued him
grampster says question in The Last of
Us uh a cordyceps fungus has turned the
human race into murderous Mushroomhead
zombies evidently this is based on real
science and insects should we be
concerned no no we're probably fine no
we're probably fine there's a lot of
[__] that's hoax that is hoaxes and
science fiction that people think is
real
me and uh my friend from Saudi Arabia
sod we were talking about it today he's
he's a he's a medical student
and uh we were talking about these
pandemics
and he was pointed out a lot of stuff
just all kinds of other experts saying
that pandemics
as they were a long time ago like the
black plague and they aren't possible
anymore
uh just because of living conditions
people showering uh the Advent of not
drinking poop water you're not drinking
poop water
what was it uh the Advent of [__] uh
uh penicillin
it's just you can have outbreaks
but what happens is people get sick and
they go home and when they go home they
stop spreading it in in modern
conditions that's not what would happen
in the olden days they get sick but home
was just packed with with a bunch of
other people you could spread it at home
because the population density was real
high and that and people didn't have an
understanding of what
what a disease was so they didn't know
how to avoid it treat it or prevent it
you can have an outbreak but it wouldn't
ever go pandemic not anymore this is
some this is science fiction
it's just trying they're just trying to
sell
fear control they want that digital
currency and that did in that [__] um
that world passport they're trying to
make a world government that's all it is
so it's um Pfizer and all them guys
involved but there can't be a pandemic
it would have happened already
Zach says uh also you guys need to watch
The Last of Us it's so good I know Tom
will love it it's basically if Cormac
McCarthy wrote The Walking Dead yeah see
that's what I kind of like I'm not super
super into like post-apocalyptic stuff
but like Tom really likes it I like that
kind of [__] and everybody's talking
about that show how many seasons are
there I think it just started right and
what was the first season yeah what what
uh it's based on that video game right
it's like it's post-apocalyptic video
game is that on um
that's on uh Netflix or is that where is
that you get that on what you call it uh
I don't think it's Netflix I don't
remember I don't really remember it
might be I don't remember what streaming
service it's on because I mean we have
so many I mentioned AMC I saw some
things recently they're saying they
think AMC maybe has months to live they
don't think AMC is going to make it
um
hpmx HBO Max yeah I'm not buying them I
have hbmx you do yeah but you got it for
free or for some Services I got it
through my phone plan okay
yeah we've been watching stuff on there
all the time okay the uh
I was gonna say AMC does not gonna make
it you know you know that stubs thing
now they want to charge you for sitting
in good seats even though it's empty
isn't that something yeah the seats
towards the prime seats in the middle
are now going to cost more
now I think
I think that also applies with if you
had that stubs thing that would kill you
know if I can watch the free movies they
charge you extra for it and they would
do that even if the [__] even if the
theater was empty
that's ridiculous they're getting like
Airlines now yeah
they charge more well they're get
they're getting desperate for money and
it caused them to lose it's causing them
to lose more money so it's just a sign
that that's going it's a shame because
AMC was a great theater chain I I well
yeah I used to really like going there
we just stopped going mostly because you
know it's too far it's too far
too far and they have but
um you know they have lots of locations
across the United States and in some of
these States they're just not doing well
although who knows maybe uh
if they were smart
they would just close all the
unprofitable locations they might be
able to keep it afloat but I think
from what they were saying you know
there's a AMC was built on a lot of
borrowed money and who knows you know
they probably have big overheads big
bill payments and [__]
yeah it's um
that's the thing I kind of feel like
it's it's one of those I don't think the
the margins are as razor thin as like a
restaurant for example right but they
don't have a huge profit margin because
they have to pay a lot of money
um you know the equipment isn't cheap
and they uh have to pay a lot of money
for the rights to like share the movies
and stuff like that that's one of their
biggest what I would have done if I was
EMC you know you know that that app that
that they that we had that was a nice
app
yeah I would have done it to where
you had the option to either go either
to go into the theater or stream it live
through your
tablet and maybe cast it onto your
television
that way you didn't have to go to the
theater well I thought that they were
kind of starting to go that way like
some like some movies were doing like a
hybrid kind of thing where it's like
they would just show in the theater but
you could also like watch it at home
like for the same amount of money or
whatever because that way you'd get more
eyes on the [__] screen even though
it wasn't the screen that they you know
what I mean the physical screen it was
just uh on their tablet or on their [__]
you know it would be just like any other
it'd be like it would basically be like
Netflix
or not yeah let me like Netflix that's
the way they should have gone
where you have physical locations but
you could also just stream it that'd
have been a lot better
because we probably would have still
kept it or at least there's kept one of
them
yeah because then we would be able to
watch the movies yeah because we didn't
have to drive yeah
because there are I would have watched
them yeah there's a ton of movies that
came out that I wanted to see and it's
like we never got down and I just never
got down there because it was so far
yeah
John Smith said I always thought Cinemas
made their money out of overselling
popcorn and sweets well they they do
that but that's because like I said
because the margins on everything else
are like really thin so they have to
like overcharge for like sodas and food
and stuff but um and justice for me said
always smuggle in your food yeah yeah we
did it all the time like normally I'll
buy a drink because I can't sit for two
hours without having something to drink
or uh you know my I get cottonmouth so I
will like buy a soda
or you know or something to drink but we
always go to like CVS or something like
that there's some gummy bears and [__]
he gets Gummy Bears I usually get like
peanut m m there were times I was
walking in there man you could hear me
crinkling
you can hear the [__] Juju fruits
[__] in the Box
I'm trying to play it off but then I'm
going why am I playing it off this kid's
[__] 17 man here thick hair he
doesn't give a [__] yeah and I'm walking
it's not coming out of his salary they
don't pay him enough
you know what I mean what's he gonna do
it's like you know what are you gonna do
like confront to somebody like they come
into food and like get in the fight
security like right he's got candy
they're not gonna bother yeah I think
like as long as long as you're not
making like a
kill if you if you can if they're gonna
bust you on your way in that's it I'm
[__] killing my subscription and they
lose out on their 20 bucks a month but
uh the thing is some of us you know
somebody just mentioned will they make
all their profits off the caddy and the
concession says yeah but they wouldn't
have to if most of their business
um was uh just online then there there'd
be no expense at all it's free money
coming out of cyberspace yeah you'd have
people in the middle of butt [__] Egypt
that are down there in [__]
Mississippi and [__] Heidelberg you
know I mean where it was there's not an
AMC for [__] 200 miles you'd have
them down there watching it on the
screen for 20 a month
which is that's how Netflix worked you
know but in this imagine if Netflix also
had theaters you could go to you know
that's that's what it should have been
yeah
well like I said I kind of feel like
it's going that way a little bit because
there have been like some movies that
were like kind of hybrid releases where
they came out in the theater
um for a day or two and then like they
started streaming it for like 20 or
whatever it was so
Tom's and glorious bastard says hahaha
Really Gummy Bears I always thought you
would be a Big League Chew type of guy
no
no gummy bears uh juji fruits Mike and
Ike Mike and Ike's he likes all that
kind of that gross like licoriceye yeah
yeah yeah black licorice yuck um
especially I like the Scandinavian black
licorice man it's like eating them
it's almost kind of salty it's almost
like eating beef jerky which is really
good
you can't see we can't find much of it
over here what else was I eating um
oh the damn
[__]
sourheads and nerds and all those I'll
eat those I'll eat anything uh Jolly
Ranchers
like that Starbursts I like Starbursts
but that's about the only that kind of
candy that I like yeah
the one I kind of have to have in the
theater like if is uh
uh gummy bears gummy bears and juji
fruits yeah I like Juju fruits the best
just depends you can't get good Juju
fruits all the time because remember
those are the ones that we were like
debating what those [__] shapes were
supposed to be right yeah they were made
out of random [__]
vegetables the only molds they have only
molds that they had a piece of corn uh
one of them is the one that looks like
teeth it looks like a damn hot dog with
four bumps on the top it's supposed to
be a pea pod with peas in it yeah
um
we're gonna I went down the Wikipedia
Rabbit Hole in that one day because I
got curious the little round ones are
supposed to be cauliflowers I think yeah
yeah they were they were vegetable molds
yeah that's like all they had that's all
they had and then after a while like
people just got used to it and they're
like oh whatever [__] it it like doesn't
have anything to do with the flavors
yeah but yeah well that's the thing like
whenever we go
when we go to the movies and you would
go get all the candy you would get like
several several boxes because sometimes
like no joke he would go into the
theater like with boxes stuffed in every
pocket so he'd have like five or six
boxes and he would just like sit there
and eat them like making noise and [__]
yeah
whereas like look if I'm gonna get candy
like as much as I like to have like a
whole [__] ton of candy I can't eat that
much candy all right it's like I'll be
400 pounds so it's like um so usually I
would just get one single like box of
peanut M M's and a drink and that was
all I had and I would usually eat them
before the movie [__] started because
I said you said peanut M Ms and I tasted
them man I want some peanut M M's now
I mean regular M Ms are good but peanut
M M's are clearly are clearly Superior
yeah like clearly far superior
actually um I think for a while they had
some M M's that were like why don't we
just they were kind of like they weren't
malt but they were kind of like Whoppers
you know what I mean yeah where they had
like those too yeah those were good too
they've come out with like some new
flavors but I haven't really been um
trying any of them because residents oh
no [__] those I love those you know it's
just like raised I don't like raisins
raisinets I like the um I like snow caps
yeah I like snow cats they're okay
they're not they're not that special
yeah but you know there's I like them
because they have the little Reese's
Peanut Reese's Pieces that's almost says
Reese's penis penis Reese's Reese's
penis
Reese's Pieces yeah yeah please tell me
his porn name
he's telling me that for Valentine's Day
Reese's like sells little chocolate
peens with peanut butter inside no
actually with marshmallow inside would
be better yeah
another good porno would be like dick
hammer
hahaha
you know what's [__] up is like I
think that could that could be someone's
actual name can you imagine
yeah mine is dick dick Hammer dick
Hammer [__] man damn that's a poor name
is [__] private detective's name my
name is dick dick
dick hammer
okay
I just feel like if that was your porn
name though it's like just that's way
too obvious that's like for that's like
from the 70s when everything was like
when they had to make everything as
obvious as possible yeah they now they
have a little bit more Fitness I feel
like but you know what I mean all the
good names were taken I guess
[Laughter]
yeah Justice for me said uh can you
imagine them pulling some TSA [__] and
patting you down yeah see that's the
thing it's like the kids that work in
there they don't give a crap if you
can't [__] candy in they know
everybody does it yeah like I said I
guess as long as you're not flaunting it
yeah cons and you're talking about the
big chunk yeah the chunky
chunky bars those are [__] good too
for you foreigners
and it caused a foreigner too he's in
Mexico but they must have him down there
chunky chunky bar was a chocolate bar
that was about that big and about that
thick yeah four big pieces they had them
they came in different flavors
I don't know if they still make them in
different flavors but someone would just
chocolate the other one was chocolate
with nuts chocolate with uh raisins and
I think they had one was chocolate with
the Rice Krispies in it I think they had
that one too yeah they were good and uh
at certain times I think they made them
bigger
like they'd come up with a special
edition it was like twice the size it
was even bigger you know
they were good
I think they still sell those right yeah
I'm pretty sure they're just rare you
don't see them in stores that much
I noticed I was in Walgreens a couple
days ago
um in Daytona because I had to go and
get like some lipstick or something
and they're starting to have all kind of
like KitKat flavors and like different
Snickers flavors and stuff and I'm like
[__] finally man remember how
everybody used to piss and moan about
like why does Japan get like all the
cool KitKat flavors they got strawberry
kitkats wasabi green tea and wasabi and
all that and they got all those crazy
like Pringles flavors and [__] like that
too like pumpkin spice and all that kind
of well I think they have those here too
yeah but um but yeah now they're
starting to like uh do them over here I
had one what did I get the other day I
was like in a 7-Eleven and I think I got
the birthday cake
KitKat and that was actually pretty good
it wasn't as good as I was hoping
but it was like white chocolate and it
was like vanilla e so it was pretty good
though
I just feel like a lot of the white
chocolate ones kind of just taste like
white chocolate nothing that not there's
anything wrong with that I really like
white chocolate but I'm just saying
they have to have more like types of
birthday cakey flavor you know what I
mean yeah huge anus a huge a gay
Superstar
Tammy said I sent you some for Christmas
a few years ago
yeah probably yeah yeah yeah anything
you get well don't say that
we know who it's from because that well
then some people would be sending some
weird ass [__] like to make us eat it on
the show and I'm just like not gonna
have it you know yeah
they're gonna make us eat like crickets
and whatnot
I saw like um I was watching a show the
other day was one of those baking shows
that was on Netflix and they put what
did they make cupcakes or cookies or
something like that and they put some
[__] crickets yeah [__] all that but
that well the people at Adam said you I
mean you couldn't tell it was crazy if
they like ground them all up I mean they
told them it was crickets obviously but
it's like it's like you couldn't really
tell what it was yeah try to get people
to eat bugs
every like everybody that I've heard
that's eaten that's eaten crickets they
said they just kind of taste like it's
gonna be much there like popcorny or
something like that
you're not supposed to be eating chitin
chitin's not you know not very good and
the the only cultures that eat insects
were ones that went through a bunch of
damn famine you know uh
Thailand and that's not normal for them
you know what I mean they're saying this
is not what they normally ate they just
had this
I think it was some kind of a weird
oppressive regime that went through
there to change their diet for the same
thing with China they'll eat cockroaches
and [__] [__]
deep fried cockroaches matter if I can
eat that [__] man crazy
it's not food it's not good for you
John Smith said I recently tried
birthday cake flavored tea it was
everything I ever dreamed of was it
really did it actually really taste like
birthday cake
I really like
um they have that birthday cake vodka
that's that's actually quite good I just
like it's a very distinctive
flavor that that frosting kind of flavor
you know what I mean it's almost kind of
like an artificial frosting flavor yeah
but I don't think it is official it's
just vanilla and and
what they call icing sugar
and uh
it might have and butter probably
but frosting is usually butter butter
and sugar
I like that rule I mean all kind of
frosting is good but
you can also it's butter
cream cheese and sugar and the coloring
and the flavor right that's another
thing exactly you whip it together
that's that's another way you can do it
there's been a bunch of different ways
to do it over the years I think some of
them
I think some of them were butter and
Mayo better in mayonnaise with uh I
think that's a real old school [__]
butter with mayonnaise and [__]
frosting you know powdered sugar and
vanilla and
it came out it comes out real creamy
you can put it on a cake
I don't know how long it would keep
but uh probably pretty good though you
can do all kind of fun things with
mayonnaise yeah
I know people some people are like you
but it's like all it is it's eggs and
oil pretty much so you just need
something to hold the hold the frosting
into a certain shape it has to have the
right texture but you know after all
that sugar
and the butter or you know you're not
going to be able to taste it
was something else that had remember
that damn ambrosia salad that had a
bunch of mayonnaise in it mayonnaise and
sugar
I think it's called ambrosia salad um
well okay Ambrosia is that is that the
same as Waldorf salad like Waldorf salad
yeah everybody calls it something
different I think it's similar like
across yeah I think I think Ambrosia
salads it's like Waldorf salad but I
think it's different it's got different
stuff in it I think it's got oranges in
it you like mandarin orange chocolate
pieces like spices
yeah but it's kind of it's that's how I
remembered it coconut flakes yeah
canned pineapple yeah that's some 60
[__] maraschino cherry yeah
I mean it's good but it's just like it's
a weird style yeah I feel like people
people still make it now but like for
retro potlucks and stuff like that yeah
only old people know about it there's
another version of it that I think is
called green stuff yeah that has
isn't that I think it's cool whip but
maybe it has like pistachio in it hence
the green I can't really remember but
there's like a lot of different
um variations of it
big little says use mayonnaise instead
of butter when making grilled cheese
yeah I've heard that yeah I've heard
that I've heard that and you can make
like a pretty Kick-Ass uh pie crust just
with mayonnaise and uh flour I think I
can't remember I think it's like a two
ingredient type of thing
um
Tom's glorious bastard said roast's
roasted crickets with lime and salt
don't taste bad yeah I've heard that
they don't really
that they taste okay you know what I
mean it's just
I don't like all the legs you know what
I mean
yeah Hugo said I had crickets while
visiting uh some that place in Mexico
um they're crunchy they put salt lime
powdered chili they're good
those who's saying this
Hugo Hugo okay Khan said he ate some of
those
crickets
it lives in Mexico
they think they're deep frying them and
had them in some paper I wouldn't eat
that though
that's bait man
so we used to catch fish
yeah I'm just like I said I'm a little
grossed out by like the by the legs more
than anything like I I can't like say
too much because I eat shrimp and those
are essentially bugs of the sea but you
know what I mean yeah but you're not
eating a shell that's yeah exactly see
that's that's or the legs that's the
problem there's not much meat in that
there's not much protein in that it's
it's a lot of it's chitin and I don't
know what the effects of eating chitin
are especially if you eat a lot of it
I'm sure it's probably not good for
myself
that's for sure most things aren't well
it'd be like eating fingernails yeah or
eating a bunch of hair that wouldn't be
good
you know your stomach acid is going to
go in there and try to break that down
and there's going to be a bunch of that
would probably sulfur you know it's just
uh
probably give you bad heartburn if you
weren't ready for it yeah I don't know
Zach says raisin or chocolate chip with
oatmeal cookies
what chips actually uh
walnuts Jenny doesn't like raisins I
don't like raisins I like them I like
I'll eat raisins in anything
any of those cookies and [__]
I mean I don't hate them but I'm they're
always like disappointing like I'm
always kind of like disappointed it's
like hey here I have this delicious
cinnamon bun and I'm like oh thank you
very much oh it has raisins in it oh
I mean I'm still gonna eat it anyway
probably but I would just rather there
not be raisins in it you know what I'm
saying
they're just I don't know they just
taste like sadness I don't I don't
really like them
Oaxaca yeah that's right I remember like
somebody told me how to pronounce it
once and for whatever reason I forgot
I said that's what they call that cheese
right yeah wow it's a place yeah it's a
place I had bought some of that over
here at the damn Mexican store [__] was
expensive man how much was it for that
same amount of money I could have got
about a couple pounds of damn that's
mozzarella like the good kind yeah the
cakes
oh yeah a mozzarella
well you know I guess
it's gonna be handmade here
and that's uh
gonna be some Choice [__] you know what
I mean
these Mexicans and Central Americans
that are here they want to taste a home
they're ready to pay for it
and but the thing is is that it was good
cheese but it tasted like string cheese
to me that would be the closest to it
string cheese yeah you know like when
you're a little kid yeah like that when
you talking about a little kid I like I
like string cheese I buy those every now
and then yeah still string cheese that's
good it's good for a snack yeah
it's just yeah this is protein
kfk said uh Shredded carrot salad with
pineapple raisins and walnuts yeah
that's really good yeah
except for the raisins
and then he said best cabbage slaw ever
my barbecue place told me how to slice
they use a commercial ice crusher
the cabbage is thin fine and creamy best
slaw I ever had a commercial ice crusher
to chop up the Cabbage that's what he's
saying yeah oh okay
I'm not a big coleslaw fan you know oh
if it's done right it's good yeah I know
it's good but it's just it's like I said
it's kind of like raisins it's like I
don't hate them
but it's like
picnic food man I would just like rather
not eat it
I'll eat it if it's all that's available
but I'm not gonna be like all that
jazzed about it that's all I don't know
why
uh dream destination for a vacation
says Zach mine is Norway yeah actually I
would I would like to go to Norway one
day too
um gosh I don't know there's so many
places I haven't been
I was really into like I really wanted
to go to Italy for like a long time and
like for years we were I was actually
like planning on going but I never
did get around going but I still would
like to go I think
um I'd like to go to Japan
lots of places pretty much anywhere I'd
like to go [__] anywhere because I
never again I never get to go on
vacation so it would be nice to just go
someplace Japan's been expensive
well it's a big expense I mean we're
just talking hypothetically yeah I don't
have the money to go anywhere right now
so it's like it's you know just kind of
talking about whatever
yeah super shredded cabbage
yeah I don't know like
some of my best vacations
I don't know that most of my best
vacations were
had like other things like I was usually
like when I went to the UK I was usually
visiting my ex-husband's family so it
wasn't like a vacation vacation because
we had to like deal with his family and
stuff but
I don't know I always had a good time in
New York City like I went there a bunch
of times for vacation
yeah
but
there's a lot of other places I'd like
to go
Zach says I'd also love to see South
Africa
yeah that might be cool too I never
really thought about going there
that's probably cool I wouldn't mind
going like all around Europe you know
like seeing all the capitals and stuff
because like mostly I've just been in
the UK that's it
and then when I was over there I was
thinking oh maybe we should go to France
because it's like right there but we
just never got around to it
so that guy I didn't even get to go to
Scotland and that's like right there
which I was like [__] man I wouldn't go
to South Africa though if I was going to
go to Africa I'd go to Nigeria
they had that guy he's got that channel
called sabbatical
and he would go all over the African
continent he'd have a good time uh but
that [__] out to Africa uh the best
thing going right now over there would
have been Nigeria
got new cities and stuff
people were nice to him
boys what all is cool about it like
it's kind of an up-and-coming place you
know I mean they've got some cities
there that are getting their [__]
together the government's supposed to be
pretty decent it's trying to better the
better the living conditions and move up
in the world you know
they're not selling out to uh
foreign power so much
I think they're involved with the
Chinese but they're not letting the
Chinese [__] them over and they're
supposed to be pretty good
um that's where um
uh
that's where that um what's the name
Empress joji she was Nigerian remember
that that that girl is doing all the
reaction videos yeah
she got married
do you know that I think yeah she got
married she put her wedding on there and
I was joking with her says oh you
started that channel and got you got you
a rich man she goes yeah I did
you had a nice car and [__]
big old wedding
John Smith said France is great Paris
not so much
yeah I was kind of I would like to go to
Paris but there's like France is a very
very huge country I'd like to go to like
some other places in France too but you
know I have to brush up on my French I
don't remember much of it
um Camp guy said wants to go to Bali
Indonesia go surfing in the best
conditions in the world especially good
waves for beginners
I got a bunch of like my uncles and
cousins are like real into surfing I
never really got into it though
you know
probably I'm not like super coordinated
I hate the ocean because I'm scared of
sharks
because I grew up right next to the
[__] ocean you know
I was watching if you guys
um there's a channel on YouTube most
some of you guys might already know
called nexbo he usually talks about like
yeah creepy [__] like he talks about um
args and stuff like that mostly and he
put up a video the other day that I
think was just called fear of the deep
and it was like this half hour 35 minute
video and he was doing like this
exploration of
um I can't remember the word
philosophobia something like that where
um
it's very very common fear like people
are really afraid of like deep oceans
and have
um recurring nightmares about being down
in like this big black void and like
these huge
you know fish or like creatures like
swimming past you and stuff and so he
was talking about that fear and he
talked about like some video games and
allergies and stuff like that that uh
leaned into that fear and it was like
actually like a really good video
because I have had like recurring dreams
like that pretty much my whole entire
life like of just being down in the
Black Ocean and then like some massive
Behemoth like coming out of the
Blackness you know what I mean
and it's interesting because a book that
I was just reading I just finished
reading it hopefully I'll get a review
of it put up this weekend but
um it's called the house that fell from
the sky
and it kind of had some
stuff along those lines you know what I
mean it had like kind of a lovecraftian
kind of like thing to it toward the end
and there were some scenes where
you know like someone would be in like a
room and like the ceiling would be glass
and they would see like these massive
like
kind of like sea creatures or like big
lovecraftian like elder god type things
like kind of swimming or flying around
like and it kind of like freaked me out
like caring about it you know what I
mean
uh Toms and glorious bastards fun facts
if you want a Nigerian woman you need to
pay the father a significant number of
cows hahaha no joke
don't ask how I know this take that yeah
how many cows how many cows did you have
to pay
[Laughter]
how many cows do you have
I mean
I'd love to know what my value in cows
cows was I'm sure there's probably some
app online that gives you your your
value in cows I feel like we were what
were we talking about this some other
time
I don't know because I feel like I kind
of looked it up at some point so we must
have been like talking about it I was
like is there an app that like that
tells you how much you're worth in terms
of cows like in certain countries maybe
I read it somewhere and I looked it up
because I thought that would be funny
John Smith said there's the condition of
Paris syndrome
the disappointment of people that travel
to Paris and feel the city was not what
they'd expected from the movies I wonder
if a lot of people have that coming to
the U.S because I kind of feel like
I'm always really interested too in
um
like British people that live in the U.S
or that visited the us and what they
found interesting about it or what
surprised them and I feel like even
though
nowadays you'd think that you know
because of the internet like everybody
kind of knows everything about
everything but you'd think that people
would have different expectations but
people still have expectations like
based on American movies you know what
I'm saying because I kind of feel like
one of the things that they always
mention like particularly British people
like coming to the U.S is that they're
like well in American movies it seems
like everybody like has a lot of money
and has like these big massive houses
and stuff like that and they said well a
lot of people here do have like massive
houses like way bigger than they would
have in Europe but it's like there's a
lot of poverty too which they don't
really show in American movies a lot or
at least the ones that they've seen so
that's always something that always
really surprises them is they kind of
they're like we kind of get the
impression that everybody lives in these
big like mcmansions because it's like
that's usually what you see like in
movies and on TV a lot of people do
limit it though they do but but it's not
everybody like they think it's like
everybody but I'm like no there's a lot
of people living in like dumps here too
yeah and there's a lot of homeless
people and [__] like that also oh
well there's not a lot of homeless
people there's there are homeless but
most people do live in houses
um
most people live
in these 1950s looking houses that were
small they were small Southern houses
that back in the 50s
they were um nice houses nice Middle
Class Type houses
but building standards and Styles have
changed a lot since then so that's now
all kind of like the uh the
that one called the poor neighborhood
but they're like the lower middle class
neighborhoods working class neighborhood
a lot of people still live in the I mean
I lived in a neighborhood like that when
I grew up and I lived in one you know
when I lived in Daytona my house was
built in 1958 and it was just like a
little bitty yeah they tend to be made
out of cinder block as they last forever
um
it tend not to have too many windows so
they kind of feel dark and damp
um they don't have central air a lot uh
some of them been retrofitted with
Central
heating and air but a lot of its window
units
um
the floors are kind of like slabs of
concrete and they're cracked by now uh
with tiles
maybe throw Carpets on it and everything
the houses are old now oh yeah
wood paneling on certain interior walls
it looked pretty tacky
um
you can get one of those for nothing
but here's the thing a little bit more
you can get a brand new one that's
a lot nicer
like when we infiltrated the rich people
neighborhoods or that last place but a
lot of people couldn't believe that we
lived through there and then when we
when we oh they're like how could you
afford this well how much is you paid
and it we were only paying a little bit
more than them
yeah I mean the thing about it
particularly in Orlando and stuff like
that
um you can't get anything for less than
fifteen sixteen hundred dollars yeah
unless like an apartment I'm talking
right I mean unless it's a complete
[__] right
I mean I had an apartment
um back in 2009 2010 and I paid like 700
a month for a one bedroom and it was not
awful but it was in like kind of a [__]
neighborhood and it was kind of roach
infested yeah
it's over 1700 you get an okay apartment
maybe a good apartment
but for 2000 or 2100 you get a nice
house
you know 10 years old looks like
something out of a movie palm trees and
[__] big glass
windows and glass sliding us you know
a little bit more you can get a
two-story house like this actually this
is about the same this ends up being
what 2500 about that
yeah it's about 2500 something like that
yeah which uh we can kind of afford yeah
now that Jenny went back to work that
and then got the new roof roofing tiles
are sitting on top of the [__] house
right yeah I thought they were supposed
to
when they're ready when they're ready
when they're ready they just came when
they come they came on Tuesday right
they came on Tuesday while I was at work
and put all the stuff on the roof yep
and then like I keep coming home every
day and being like well it's still there
it's Friday today and I'm like well they
still haven't done it yet
I paid the down payment the financing
has all gone through and everything and
they just okay we're gonna do it we're
gonna put it up there we'll
we'll be down there they they said would
be sometime this week but it's only a
two-day job I don't really care just as
long as they get it done
yeah I mean you know yeah so I don't
care I'm not here so I don't give it
makes a [__] ton of noise hopefully I'll
sleep through it
I mean well yeah the only thing I was
worried about was like oh what did you
know if I have to record a video or
something like that but it's like if
it's not going to be during the night
and it's not going to be on the weekends
so you'll be at work you'll never see it
happen yeah
I kept expecting him to come and do it
but yes they just didn't because like I
said I'm gonna I'm gonna do a you know a
video this weekend but you know because
I finished reading that book and I was
gonna do a review of it
and I need to catch up on my
scare salon videos and all that other
kind of stuff so I'm trying to do like
at least like one a week for across all
my channels just because I don't have a
lot of time you know what I mean and as
soon as it seemed like as soon as I went
back to work and like don't have any
time to do anything now it's like now I
got like a whole bunch of other
freelance work too so it's like last
weekend I did a bunch of freelance work
and then this weekend I got a bunch of
freelance work I gotta do not as much as
last week but I got a whole bunch I
gotta do tomorrow like some posters and
[__] like that I gotta make but you know
it's all money it's just
you know I get sleepy I'm tired and I
feel like I don't have any time to do
anything else you know what I mean well
you don't yeah not for now I know it'll
work out though it'll leave it out
give it a couple months
yeah I know you just you're just pissed
because
you haven't really gotten a decent
paycheck in yet but it's all coming
yeah I mean once the money starts
showing up you'll feel a lot better
well you know it's it's still kind of
like it's still a long drive and I'm
still worried about my car and yeah all
that kind of stuff anything goes wrong
with the car we'll just uh
we'll just get you another one
well I know that but it's like I don't
have any money right now to get in
because I'm behind on so many bills and
stuff you gotta pick you gotta you you
gotta do something you gotta catch up oh
gee I know thanks you're gonna catch up
it'll happen
never you haven't failed any time before
everything you know what I mean
it always works out
yeah but that doesn't mean that I can't
fail
and sometimes I do fail for a time you
know what I mean
then I have to like [__] get it all
back together again Zach says I have a
channel for you then my English World
he's this cute Russian guy who moved to
Texas he does reaction videos and live
streams he's adorable and funny as [__]
oh I'll have to look that up yeah I'm
fascinated by
different cultures perceptions of one
another
like I always find that really
interesting I really like
um that guy Lawrence from Lost in the
pond who like I said he's uh British but
he's lived in the United States for 14
15 years and he's a citizen now but he's
married to an American woman and he
lives in like the Midwest and he's lived
in like Chicago or something like that
and so he does a lot of videos and he's
really funny and then there's
um there's a couple
who the [__] are they actually there's
two couples that are cute that like
doing but I can't remember what their
names are right now but um both of them
still live in the UK but they do a lot
of videos about
learning things about the US and it's
like oh this surprised us about Bloody
blood and sometimes they visit the US
and like they'll go in the grocery store
and like talk about all the [__] look
at all the cereals you know what I mean
and all this other kind of stuff
because they have a lot of the same [__]
over there but it's just like they don't
have as many
you know saying that that could take you
to work on the back of the motorcycle no
if a guy that came down to that I'd buy
a new car
yeah my credit's good I could go get a
used yeah you could I couldn't I could
get
what let me finish what I'm saying
I could get a four or five thousand
dollar used car just let her use that
so I don't like riding the back of the
motorcycle anyway yeah it's scary I
don't even like [__] driving the car
like in all the traffic and stuff like
that and this we I thought it was going
to be like the traffic's gonna be worse
today because I had forgotten but the
[__]
um
what's that goddamn the big NASCAR race
is this weekend so I was at work today
and like they have you know this uh the
planes the Blue Angels you know the
stunt planes and all that kind of [__]
um they were practicing all day today
and we and where I work is like only a
mile or two from the airport
and only a mile or two from the um from
the racetrack so it's like we heard the
[__] Blue Angels like we just heard
[__] Sonic booms all day long yeah
the Daytona 500 that's what you think
I'd know that because I grew up there
but yeah I forgot because I was like
when I was coming home last night like
the traffic was so bad and it was just
like so slow and it's like I felt like I
was never gonna get out of [__]
Daytona and I'm just like sitting there
at lights and it's just backed up and
I'm like what the [__] and I was like
the flea market was open and it was
Thursday I'm like what the [__] is going
on and then I was like oh it's February
which means that it's probably around
time for the Daytona 500 because I
remember
how [__] shitty that was like them
being all and I kind of feel like
probably next month is
Bike Week
so
I'm kind of hoping next week at work
won't be too bad because maybe everybody
will be gone
by the time I will maybe they won't
though when does it start I don't even
know but I hate that I have to like
check but I guess I have to check
because otherwise otherwise I might not
be able to get into it because like I
said where I work is like right by the
[__] Speedway
Tom's Inglorious Bastards that Tom can
uh attach a co-pilot seat like an
Indiana Jones
like a sidecar oh Sidecar
John Smith said fun fact the Blue Angels
is the name of a Scottish Outlaw biker
gang the Hell's Angels never got a
foothold here
I did not know that
well I thought it was like an old movie
called Blue Angel or something like that
right but yeah the Blue Angels are like
a real famous
they you know they do like stunt like
playing stunt [__] you know what I mean
what do they call that oh I'm too tired
to like think of anything
they're acrobatics yeah yeah so they
were they were practicing today yeah but
the name of the Outlaw motorcycle gang
is blue angels that
man
that's that sounds like damn cheerleader
in Squad man or like I said some kind of
Stunt Squad
that doesn't sound like a [__] outlaw
biker gang to me
[__]
eat a man up
although they probably get mad for me
making fun of that name yeah they're
gonna pound you in the [__] pole
worried about them
got warlocks here and [__] Banditos
I always thought it'd be funny as angels
I always thought it'd be funnier to give
your like Outlaw biker gang like you'd
be like the worst of the worst but give
them like a really innocuous sounding or
really like
um really girly sounding name or really
something like that said nobody would
nobody would expect it it's like ooh
here come the powder puffs or whatever
and then they come in like dick suckers
and then they come and like beat your
ass
and they all they're all like seven feet
tall these big hulking like yeah brutes
and stuff that'd be [__] hilarious
because they wouldn't have anything to
worry about they wouldn't have because I
kind of feel like if you're in a gang
and you have to give yourself like a
really tough sounding name yeah to me
that comes across this little a little
try hard they're not gangs really
they're clubs they can't call themselves
a gang
they're not really I guess they have to
have the they have to have at least the
trappings of a motorcycle club
if not then the [__] although you
know I mean whatever
they the thing is is that
I see them around
they don't have a lot of young members
though
it looks like they're aging out you know
a young a young one would be in his 40s
which uh
that's not a good sign you want members
that are in there in in their 30s in
there too you know 20s and 30s
it's just um
motorcycle clubs are I think we're a
thing of the 60s you know yeah I don't
really think that's a big that's huge
that's not really translating to into
the younger Generations that much
and um
when you see them they're not really
um impressive
specimens of physicality you know
they're not in real good shape
they tend to be veterans
but they're
they're having weight problems
you can tell that they're not real
um
Physically Active
or not as active you know you can tell
they're not beating people up on a
regular basis yeah I'm not saying that
they're safe
they're dangerous
um but
and it depends on which ones you're
talking about too you know I mean I've
seen photographs of Mongols that look
pretty [__]
tough
um you can tell they're on juice
some of them at least
um
some of the [__] one percenter held's
Angels kind of like that
I guess it just depends you know yeah I
mean
some bikers it looks like the only thing
they're beating up is the buffet a
Cracker Barrel yeah what I'm saying yeah
not that there's anything wrong with
that
but then you'll run across one of them
every now and then you know
online you'll see them photographs of
them or videos of them at some event
and they're wearing all the [__]
right [__] that you know what it is
you're dealing with and
you know you didn't want to tank with
the dude he's [__] six one two
hundred and [__]
30 pounds
a 10 body fat he's [__] jacked you
know he's and he's 50 something but you
know you know he's Sauced he's not
natural
um but you nobody older than 35 is going
to look like that natural you know it's
just not gonna happen yeah
but they look like something out of a
movie
but that's like the top
Elite dudes you know from those clubs
they're kind of like uh
Warrior Kings from a long time ago you
know
never see the women though
rarely
I don't know what they're doing they
have their own business I guess
I'm not big into that fashion I hang out
at the biker bar and [__]
I don't think I think that look is kind
of dated
but they like it you know but it's to me
it's kind of country and it's kind of
dated
the very 70s look to it you know
John Smith said I always laugh at the
gang called the lone wolves a gang of
Lone Wolves yeah yeah they're all doing
their own thing yeah but all together in
one place they just all happen to be in
one place at the same time
Zach said what's the traffic going to be
like come spring break season probably
shitty but that is usually confined to
the beach side
and like I said I don't know if you know
but Daytona is
kind of too it's not two cities but it's
Mainland and Beachside and it's like a
big because there's Visa there's a big
huge River in between you know what I
mean the Halifax River and
there's like a little bit like we're a
Daytona and stuff like that is there's
like a peninsula and it goes like way
down and then there's like a the river
that comes up so there's the beach side
is kind of like a strip of land that's
only like a mile or two across and then
the ocean but then there's like a big
river and then you got like the mainland
part so usually the um
the spring break people usually usually
stay over on the
beach side question was what what biker
group was that Hunter S Thompson wrote
about that was the Hell's Angels yeah
John Smith said Hell's Angels Angels
underneath and then he said oh I'm dumb
I mean they're kind of like the big one
that everybody knows
they've been around for a long time yeah
they were I don't even remember when
maybe that'd be an interesting show to
do actually history of the Hell's Angels
it attracted a lot of attention that was
uh
they started like in the very early 50s
after the second World War
it was supposed to be uh
bomber it started with some bomber
crewmen
guys that were ball Gunners and [__]
like that and waste Gunners hanging out
in California
[__] bored to death and they just
hung out in bars and rode motorcycles
and [__] did little ad hoc
motorcycle races you know [__] across
the middle of town and
um a lot of that a lot of that [__] was
kind of fueled by fake news
they uh I think it started when they
said uh one it had a fake news report
that the Hell's Angels I think it was
Hell's Angels uh took over the town
and uh got in a fight with the police
but it didn't actually quite go down
that way and then the newspaper people
showed up and staged some photographs
um
and they described it as being a lot
bigger than what it really was and that
kind of how that was kind of how the
myth was born
now eventually the the I think it was
also the Hells Angels later on that got
in a fight with the Marines
it was like the Marine National Guard or
the Marine some kind of marine Guard
unit
was trying to remove them from some
piece of land and they got into a
shootout but I don't think anybody got
killed if I remember correctly that was
also 50s
yeah I feel like that was such a big
thing
uh at least from a Counter Culture
standpoint yeah like all the biker gang
type stuff
and then you know the media got a hold
of that and they um
they mythicized it and made it a lot
bigger than what it really was and a lot
worse than it really was well yeah
everybody wants to read about exciting
yeah nobody just wants to write about oh
there was like a little Skirmish and
really got hurt and everybody went home
it was actually on par with like the Sex
Pistols
if you were in in if you were in England
back in the 70s The Sex Pistols were
constantly on the dam
front page of the news of what kind of
[__] outrageous thing that they said
or did but you're talking about teenage
kids who don't have any money
they weren't that important the news
were making them important although the
pistols were a [__] tight band I
liked them they're real good
um
and John Lyden because the [__] for a
kid that just came out of nowhere and
basically picked it random kinda
randomly chosen by the [__] forces of
the British ghetto
he was a master Lyricist his lyrics were
really good Anarchy in the UK those are
really good lyrics man for a what 17
year old boy riding
and submission and yeah really good
lyrics bodies
and you had a lot of but anyway the the
uh
the biker scene was built on the same
kind of guys that like the sex pills so
they were they were tougher you know in
some ways they were older and they were
intended to be
World War II veterans at first
um
and uh then they started making movies
fictionalized movies about how bad
bikers were you know
sub genre yeah of like teen biker yeah
like from the 50s and 60s yeah they're
super fun like some of them are pretty
fun yeah
they did a few on Mystery Science
Theater they did like wild Rebels and
yeah the side hackers
it started with [__] Marlon Brando
with [__] uh the wild one
if you haven't seen that movie see it it
is a study of 1950s [__] morality
because they're making this dude out to
be a [__] real threat to society and
he's just a nice guy if you ask me he's
just like a cool guy yeah that's what I
mean it's just like it's really funny
well that's what I mean it's like what
you know people talk about now ooh
people are so sensitive nowadays like
[__] man back then oh man you [__]
sneeze sideways yeah and there was like
it was a big [__] deal you know what
I mean like these people were doing
literally nothing they were doing
nothing they were just they just had
motorcycles and their regular motorcycle
leather gear
and a girl becomes kind of
curious and infatuated with like uh one
of the main guys out of the group and uh
who who's being played by Marlon Brando
and I forgot what the name of that
character was Billy was it I can't
remember
and um
he's kind of a
Rebel Without a Cause type character
kind of like uh you know James Dean
which if you've ever seen Rebel Without
a Cause that's another movie about
nothing I I watched it at that as a
teenager and couldn't relate to any of
it because it's it's 1950s problems you
know what I mean I'm like why is this
guy whining you know what's he upset
about his dad for you know his dad wore
the apron so what he was cooking you
know just it was just sucking weird
trouble that's what I mean like it
literally mattered to the 50s like
little [__] yeah like they would get
upset about like the stupidest things
but nowadays like no one would even
think like why would that why would
anybody yeah so I didn't get a lot of
that I didn't get it
I also didn't really get the wild one
um you had to be in a 1950s mindset
and I couldn't achieve it
all right it's not a bad movie
but I didn't really understand the
message I didn't really get it
I told you that's why it's always
instructive to kind of watch those like
50s educational films
that they show on Mystery Science
Theater a lot because
you'll get an insight into what they
were trying what they were teaching yeah
the kids back then yeah now on the Wild
Ones Marlon Brando
he's a com he's a compelling character
in the movie
um he looks good they're really good
Stills taken from that movie and that
really had a big impact
what had a big impact on the rocker
scene
they were also in the bikes over in
England
um
but it had a big impact on the Gacy yeah
Marlon Brando became the iconic leather
daddy leather daddies are copies of
Marlon Brando from the wild one that
leather motorcycle gear that's that's
what they're talking about
if you see the movie you'll understand
why gays liked that he was a cool dude
he was a cool dude he was the kind of
guy that
a a gay dude that is having problems
hooking up that would be his fantasy
boyfriend is to meet that guy
he's not gay in the movie but
he's straight but you could see why gay
guys liked him
yeah you can see why he became iconic
you know what I mean yeah and I think it
stuck more with the gay guys than it did
the straight girls the straight girls I
don't think really care [__] about that
yeah it's kind of hard to say you know
um
Straight girls do not hold that
character as an icon
you know what I mean
not so much like not that I've really
hurt I mean that was before my time
obviously yeah so no but that to to
you look up [__] some gay leather
daddy porn today that's what the motifs
that they're playing on off of is that
character
which is 1950s
leather motorcycle gear it kind of
looked like policeman stuff it's like
cop gear go up
motorcycle cops from the 50s
War motorcycle gear
that look like police gear was all kind
of the same thing
that's the way a motorcycle gear looked
like something a cop would wear
I mean I did sort of like the 50s rocker
Greaser rockabilly kind of look I did
like that yeah I do like that look yeah
but like I said that jacket though is
like something the cops would wear yeah
and uh the pants and stuff so greasers
were also kind of like a play on a
motorcycle cop yeah you know that's a
motorcycle jacket
the facts that I read an article once
about the eating disorder Brando
apparently had and it was actually
pretty harrowing I felt really bad for
him what did he have um I remember
reading that he had one but I can't
remember what it was
uh John Smith said I preferred Public
Image Limited yeah yeah and of course
the Damned yeah oh [__] yeah pill was
great man I love the Damned and yeah I'm
slightly more into the Sex Pistols but
pil are really good too
the energy of the pistols was spot on
for the time
and there was something about the way it
looked and the sound and they were they
were good
um they weren't always good live but you
can find live performances still on
YouTube and they're they're doing pretty
good
it was years later that pill came out
and other things had solidified and
really John Lyden kind of came into his
own during that and he had a good backup
band man He had [__]
[__] what was it Billy sheenan on
Billy sheenan on [__] bass I think
and
um Steve Vai on guitar one of the
[__] best guitar players of all times
that was on that damn album it was just
called album it was generic remember it
had the rise on it Middle Road rise with
you yeah yeah yeah
it's a great album
I had a lot of their [__] I had that one
I had happy yeah that one yeah I had um
there's one called nine or nine yeah
nine
and then the other one's called what was
the other one called Seattle no Seattle
was unhappy I think yeah that was the
same goal and the other one was called
what was the stairs and flowers or
something
Romance of flowers that was the very
first flowers of romance that's right I
think it was like a little EP I don't
think it was a full album yeah
and that had almost like Proto
industrial on it yeah a lot of their
early [__] was really experimenting yeah
it was good real good
Lyden
he's an American now he's better as an
American as he is he was a British way
but
man Leiden was an interesting figure
because
of his early childhood and with the
meningitis and all that and uh
swelling of his brain and his eye going
sideways and
not getting proper Medical Care and I
think his brother died didn't he
from from there I remember correct
because the rats were in the [__]
apartment
was growing up as a kid and he had a
basically
because his brain swelled up he had a
near-death experience he was never the
same after that of course not you had a
[__] head injury you know
and he started to become defiant
and started to question things
and um that's actually what led him into
Fame you know he started to um he
differentiated himself from other people
that were around him
now you know some promoters got involved
what was his name [__] Malcolm
McLaren and yeah
so that all helped
and having access to a good wardrobe
helped through Malcolm
but um
some people [__] would they they're
going to want to ding John Lyden
for his ego he talks a lot of [__] all
right
but in in a lot of ways he deserves to
talk a lot of [__] he was as important
as as he says he was
for the evolution of rock music
which was strange for a guy who was only
like 17 when it happened
but um
with pill with like you said the pill
was better pills better than than uh Sex
Pistols I don't think it was as as
instrumental in change
Sex Pistols were
but in terms of quality
yeah pil
real good he could sing for what you
know in his own style yes you knew
exactly who you were listening to
see that's always been a lot more
important to me than yeah because look I
you know they play music at work all the
time and it's like all different genres
and a lot of mainstream stuff and things
like that it's like you know I hear
people that can sing really well like
all the time but a lot of times I can't
tell one from the other well like it's
kind of the same thing as because we've
talked about this like and in terms of
uh you know movie stars or actors and
something like that where you talk about
somebody that's like really hot or good
looking or something but it's like you
know they're attractive but they all
kind of look similar and so I kind of
feel like that's the same thing like
with a lot of singers and I think that's
why I was really into
Punk and Post Punk and stuff like that
because it's like some of those people
couldn't sing
technically but you always knew who that
was they had their own they were
vocalists saying going on yeah singers
but they were vocal and I like that
better it's like I like
I like like when a when a song comes on
that I've never heard before and like
immediately like I know who that is yeah
you know what I mean like and it doesn't
even have to be the singer either like a
lot of times like sometimes if it's like
a real distinctive guitar sound or
something like that like you can tell
immediately like who that is yeah I like
you know I like bands that are like
distinctive and I also give credit to
Malcolm McLaren I mean you know [__]
The Sex Pistols trashed him a lot you
know they didn't have a real good
relationship but he was a good barometer
of what was coming he predicted that rap
would take over and it did it did I
think uh I think Malcolm McLaren had
something to do with the six with
accelerating the success of rap
and uh
this was happening at a time when rap
and kind of like industrial almost
sounded alike you know like the Buffalo
girl song was kind of like industrial
but it had there was a lot of crossovers
it's like a crossover to it and then if
you go back to [__]
Musical Youth which is sucking reggae
basically but it had a kind of a punk
rock rap kind of a
vibe to Musical Youth and that was all
part of that same sphere that was coming
out of the British New Wave
um yeah because everybody was just
trying to try stuff right like they were
just mixing all the different genres
yeah and then the ska bands that were
coming they were really good
they were uh half British half Jamaican
bands
and specials yeah they're [__] really
good I was just listening to my car the
other day yeah
Madness they were all British guys
though in that one yeah
um
and then they would take that concept
and go [__] more new wave and you end
up with the Thompson Twins
which it had some Reggae influence I
think it had I think it had one black
member in it yeah uh but it it it was
still very British pop for the time
and then
you know me and Jenny we lived through
it man some of you guys did too
remember how powerful the [__]
British New Wave was
yeah that [__] was like man because I I
was coming like right into like I was 11
or 12 or something like that when
British knew Wave Music really really
hit oh man in the US and it was just
like a mess because I was like oh this
is it changed it really it changed
American culture it was a big deal
England was [__] punching above its
weight during that time because they had
a good education system they were
teaching their public education system
and I know there's a difference in I
think they call private schools or
public schools
the public private thing has reversed or
something I think it is yeah or it used
to be I don't know if it is but it used
to be yeah public schools that means a
free school here in the United States
yeah when we say public that's a
taxpayer fund yeah right yeah you go
there for free public schools in England
had good music departments they spent
money on that [__]
so um you had these guys with no money
they looked great though and they could
[__] sing and play instruments and
they they [__] took over the world
or at least an English-speaking world I
mean they're [__] influence is still
felt now yep like you I hear new bands
now yeah that sound like yeah them play
from back then yeah those guys that I
[__] met [__] Corey
that they're kind of sound like a
British band a little bit they do
[__] uh there's a lot of stuff that
that but the one that really was a game
changer man you could laugh at it I
don't give a [__] Duran Duran
when that first Duran Duran album hit
at Planet Earth on it in the night boat
friends of mine
that was a [__] that was like the
second coming of The Beatles that's a
great [__] album by the way that
first yeah and they got better I still
love that they got better as they went
up until the album big thing that one
wasn't that good yeah we were it's it's
funny we were just talking about this
the other day because half the songs
were good we were at mannequins yeah uh
last Saturday and he actually played
Paul Vayner DJ he actually played um all
she wants is yeah like that Duran Duran
song yeah and I was like holy [__] I
haven't heard this in a long time I was
like this is off big thing right yeah I
was like big thing was the last Duran
Duran album that I bought like back in
the day because I bought it and I was
like
I bought more I bought uh the one that
had the one that came after it uh
uh she had a lot of good songs on it it
was mellow though there was a huge hit
on it was it the one with come on down
come on John yeah okay I do like come on
that one came out what the [__] was the
name of that album [__] I forgot the
name of it I'm sure that big thing was
the last thing I bought the cassette I
bought that up and then I bought
midazadland that had left that had
electric Barbarella on it yeah Seattle
love that song I like that song it's all
right that album though was kind of like
uh it was a mix it had the the carrillio
or curcillio brothers the guys from
missing persons
she was really good it was funny though
I've seen interviews with her she hated
that music she hated every one of those
songs
isn't that funny which is weird because
like missing persons had some great
[__] songs yeah she hated it I was at
work the other day and like you had an
80s playlist going destination I know
I'm like well this is a good [__] I
forgot how good this song was yeah I was
[__] had a huge crush on Dale I was
just I was in Military Academy at the
time and she's this if you guys know
this is she's the whole band was
italian-americans all right they were
doing
New Wave Music
it was I think they were from New York
but they were [__] really weren't
they from New York they might have been
I don't know but they were getting
really big in California that's I think
that's where they were living and that's
where they were launching their career
from and Dale was this super hot little
hustler honey she was uh our Penthouse
Pet she wasn't a hustler she was a
Penthouse Pet
and
she was cute she's you know tiny skinny
boobs you know implants and [__]
and uh she could sing though she had a
really unique voice it was real high
pitch yeah you always know that still
both you know exactly that is you can't
mistake her voice for everybody else's
big blonde frizzy hair
and she was really good with style and
coming up these uh uh outfits and uh
Lady Gaga is copying Dale buzzia from
missing person a lot yeah I mean I I
kind of feel like Lady Gaga like she
gets a lot of [__] for like copying
Madonna but I was like I kind of feel
like she's a more copy copying yeah
you know what I mean which you know if
you're gonna rip somebody off like yeah
the best I guess I think he's really
ripping her off she's just like you know
homage
she's homage I don't like to be
uncharitable like that because everybody
takes influences from other people and
and look man and Dale
Dale was like 10 times cuter than
[__] Lady Gaga 10 she's I mean super
cute Italian girl
with the Italian nose and everything
she's sporting it it looks [__] great
yeah you know little Roman knows that
she had you know [__] she was cute
and uh
I think she was married to Warren when
wasn't his name
I think it was Warren she was married
yeah I can't remember because there were
two of those because they were brothers
and I think I think she was married to
them well Warren is the one that was in
Duran Duran yeah but they play I think
she was married to him but then they got
divorced but they ended up in Duran
Duran
well one of them one of them did Warren
did yeah and actually he's been in Duran
Duran for a long time it's crazy to
think about because I still think of
Duran Duran as like the original five
members like from the 80s yeah but it
hasn't been like that since because
[__] man John and Andy left uh in what
87 88 yeah because then they went and
did power station with Robert Palmer and
then the other three Simon Nick and
Roger they did Arcadia yeah which were
good great project spans I still like
that Arcadia album it's very good I got
yeah that had it had uh it was kind of
progress but I was kind of into it you
know what I mean it was good yeah I
liked it and it had a real goth
aesthetic yeah to the videos I was like
the the cover of it was beautiful like
just the whole thing was I really dug it
and I liked that they kind of went all
Goth like they all dyed their hair black
and stuff like that like for all the
videos and stuff I was like really into
that album actually yeah that was 87.
but yeah I think like John and Eddie
Taylor never came back after that so
then they went they were a three piece
for a while like when notorious came out
and then I think for the next one which
I think was a big thing then they got
Warren cucaro and I think he's been in
there since then
if I'm not mistaken I I kind of lost
track of them after a while
because I kind of feel like the thing
about Duran Duran I was like I really
really like Duran Duran I really really
like their early stuff but I kind of
feel like after
after notorious like notorious was a
great album
um but you know I didn't love like I
kind of feel like they went more in a
direction where they were starting to
sound less distinctive I kind of feel
like even though they were like a huge
pop band in the 80s they still had a
very very distinctive sound they had
their own thing going on and I kind of
feel like as the 80s you know went into
the 90s I kind of feel like they started
sounding more like everybody else and so
I think I kind of like lost interest you
know what I mean because I like I said I
like bands that are like distinctive
once they start sounding like other
people then I'm just kind of like meh
Earth starts sounding like whatever the
main cultural Zeitgeist is I'm like not
interested John Smith said say what you
like about the Damned but Dave vanion
could sing hell yeah he could and Dave
vanion is hot as [__] sorry
isn't he still is he still married to um
Patricia Morrison who was in uh Sisters
of Mercy because I know they were
married to each other for a while and
honestly like um I haven't heard any of
the because the Damned there aren't they
still around because I kind of feel like
I bought some of their albums like a few
years back
that we're still good
Leslie said Dave anian was into goth on
deponkey dress as a vampire from the
beginning yeah he well he started out he
was a Gravedigger wasn't he like that
was the story anyways but yeah he looked
like that but their early
um their early singles were absolutely
Punk like new rose and uh Love Song and
all that kind of stuff like were were
punk bands and honestly um
there you know the Sex Pistols yeah they
kind of get a lot of the credit and
stuff but I think as far as Punk singles
coming out I think New Rose uh the
Damned New Rose I think beat the Sex
Pistols so they were actually
technically the first Punk single to be
released was the Damned
um the Damned are still touring with the
original lineup yeah I thought they were
still around because I have like a
couple of their new albums and they're
still really good I like that they kind
of went
the one that I had the most recent one I
can't remember what it's called but it's
kind of more it's almost a little bit
Psychobilly and I was kind of like into
that because I like that kind of stuff
um let's see
John Smith said to quote let me on Dave
vaney and he's very normal for a bloke
that dresses like Count Dracula
well I mean you know
that's the thing a lot of guts are
pretty normal
despite how they look
uh Leslie said for me the best Sinister
Rock album is the only theater of pain
1982 Christian day good yeah yeah that's
a that's a very [__] idea [__]
spiritual cramp
is on it [__] uh yeah Christian
definitely yeah they were good
good friend of mine is uh was friends
with uh Roz Williams
yeah that's Javier yeah I got pictures
of Javier I think I got pictures of
Javier with hanging out with him yeah
killed himself on April Fool's Day
yeah it's a waste because he was getting
better
his recordings are sounding really good
match came out it was really good
[__] it was getting better but they
never people like creative people never
see it that way you never see it that
way he's becoming the gothic David Bowie
he sounded a lot like Bowie to me
I actually really like did you ever hear
Roz Williams cover of um time yeah yeah
I really like that song
that was on my uh it's on my phone
somewhere my favorite Christian death
cover was um
[__]
1983 a mermaid I should turn to be which
is a Jimi Hendrix cover that's right and
[__] um uh Jatan Timon defeat uh did
the did the vocals
it's really good man she can [__] say
yeah she's really good holy shitieri
lover and all that yeah she's got a
great [__] voice
I remember she was [__] wowing me out
everything because
remember how how it was it was hard to
find photos of [__] goth people
[__] in the 90s you only saw them in
fanzines
yeah we were still we were still very
elusive yeah like Sasquatch
I'd go through fanzine and see pictures
all that white hair you know what I mean
[__] and she was 40 then and I was
just going like oh man that chick is hot
yeah and I think she was she was much
older than everybody else I think in
that band wasn't she
I like a lot of her solo [__] too she
like a lot of her solo [__] is like not
it's kind of like I don't even know what
genre you because it's kind of loungy
you know what I mean it's kind of like
or like jazz like jazz yeah fetish with
fetish uh lyrics
call it Jazz maybe jazz blues it's just
kind of like yeah like the kind of [__]
you used to hear like back in like the
[__] 1920s or 1930s like you go to
like some Speakeasy and some some chick
could be a collaboration like some torch
song kind of [__] like it sounds like
that like and I really really like that
like and she's got a great [__] voice
Leslie also said Peter Murphy was a
vampire dress too and he was in the
Hunger opening not being yeah yeah well
um that was because Bowie was in it and
they were like big Bowie fan boys
my interpretation was was that David
Bowie was that was his favorite band
that he was helping them not sure I've
kind of heard it both ways I've heard it
both ways
but
I still remember I laughed because
I have a book about Bauhaus I have a
couple of books about them
and they were talking about being in the
hunger and they were all the whole band
was like really excited because they're
like we get to meet with David Bowie and
we're gonna be in a movie and all this
other kind of stuff and then they're
like and then we see the movie and it
was just like all Peter Murphy and then
like
and then they were like making a joke
it's like hey Daniel I think I see your
elbow or something like that because
it's just like because they were just
like they ended it up
like you kind of say I think there's
like a two second shot of Daniel Ash
animates I don't even think David Jay is
it I don't think Kevin Haskins is in it
at all so it's like if I remember
correctly I don't know if you think I
think they're all in it you just don't
get to see very much you just don't get
a sample well you know because I mean it
just flashes up I mean Peter Murphy was
just like so back then I mean he was the
[__] and he was like super hot and yeah
and he was like doing all his thing and
all that kind of stuff so it's just kind
of like well we're just gonna focus on
that but
and I had honestly forgotten because I
hadn't listened to his solo stuff for a
while I mean you know we hear Cuts you
up at the club all the time but
um I was on my uh when I was driving
back and forth to work I've been
listening to different Spotify playlists
and one of the ones they have
that's called dark and Gothic and um it
had a couple Peter Murphy songs on it it
takes Indigo eyes on there and um
strange kind of love and I was like man
these are really good songs like I
haven't heard them in a really long time
but
I don't know I kind of feel like
I liked Peter Murphy's solo stuff up
until
we were talking about this the other day
Cascade was my the only thing the last
one that I liked Cascade that was 1995.
yeah um and that one was really good and
then he did an EP
that was pretty good
and then he did dust which I didn't like
at first but it actually kind of grew on
me it's that one's more like World music
it's very Turkish sounding because
that's where he lives in um Istanbul
because his wife is Turkish and so um
so like I didn't love it at first
because I'm like oh we're going like
Dead Can Dance Now or some [__] like
that but it's just like um you know and
I like Dead Can Dance but I'm just
saying it's like Peter Murphy didn't was
usually doing Peter Murphy stuff not
Dead Can Dance stuff but um although
Bauhaus did Cover Dead Can Dance didn't
they they did so they got in a fight
with each other they did well I did well
I mean Bauhaus did a really good but
like when they were doing their live
tours like in the late 90s they did a
cover of the Dead Can Dance on Severance
which was actually like really really
good yeah I mean the original is
beautiful but um you know the battle
house cover is good too but yeah they
they I had they got in a fight I guess
yeah and
Peter Murphy [__] accused them of
being guilty of musical tourism
this is just traffic around the world
well see but that we'll see I think
that's kind of why I laughed because
then when the Peter Murphy album just
came out but see I mean to be fair yeah
I mean Peter Murphy he's lived in Turkey
for a very long time his wife is Turkish
he speaks Turkish
um so I guess it's okay for him to do it
like that he can make an album but then
he knows a lot of Turkish musicians so
fair enough
but I don't know I just I feel like that
dude's lost it yeah I know I mean I
haven't seen him in a long time so I
don't know what he looks like now I
don't know like last time I saw him he's
gotta be bad maybe he got his [__]
together no
no drugs
drugs and bad attitude I mean he's
throwing [__] bottles at the audience
and [__] I've been [__] Scandinavian
[__] you know he's nah he's lost it
maybe maybe somebody like um did an
intervention
we've seen him live recently a couple
times you know and every time he's in
front of an audience he looks guilty
he's not sure if they know who he is you
guys know who I am yeah we know who you
are
like yeah we paid like fifty dollars
yeah
I think he knows he [__] [__] up a
lot
when he's on tour and he thinks the news
has traveled with him
so he's he's [__] very self-conscious
I've honestly I've seen Peter Murphy
live a lot of times I've seen Bauhaus
twice and I've seen Peter Murphy live
um at least a dozen times probably more
he's supposed to be very difficult to
work with but yeah I could see that yeah
well it's weird because I kind of feel
like this several times because I used
to go and see him every time he toured
which was like you know once a year or
like once every two years something like
that and um sometimes you would go see
him and he'd be like normal and he'd be
like really cool and like really
personable and stuff and then sometimes
you'd go and see him and he would be
like really imperious and standoffish
and shitty and it just like seemed like
they want to be there yeah and stuff
like that he just was kind of all over
the place that's not what he was on yeah
he did that he did that [__] hit and
run thing where he [__] wrecked the
card and ran from the thing from the
cops and he had a [__] math on him
he's [__] crackhead you know and then
he he has he actually tried to pull that
it's not mine it's not mine that's not
mine yeah and the cops are like oh my
God yeah it didn't work it didn't work
well that's because that's what
everybody says
what else are you gonna say you know
what I mean he was a dude that really
you know he had
I don't know him personally we we're
friends with a girl who knows him
personally dated him okay and
she didn't tell us everything about him
but there's just enough where you can
just [__] kind of understand what the
hell's going on
dude had a drug problem all right let's
I guess that's gonna happen you know
[__]
he was probably around that grew up
around all that stuff you know
that scene had a lot of drugs in it
yeah I feel like everybody's been on
[__] years back then the thing was
that he kind of had this image where he
was
kind of mysterious and enlightened and
real good at writing poetry and that
maybe he had some wisdom to him and some
of his lyrics do sound like that and he
may have had that at one time
but his ego is huge all right he's a
good looking guy
he was talented he was very good on
stage he's got a good voice he can write
some badass lyrics
that's not quite enough though
you got to have more to you as a man to
hold yourself together
especially if you're around all this
temptation you know drugs and women and
[__]
and
he started to slide
and I think he really prided himself on
his looks
and when the look looks started to go
I think his mentality started to go
because evidently that
he just he said things
and some in a live performance when I
saw him live in uh New Orleans
he said he told the audience he said
he is I'm still looking pretty good I
need a facelift though that's what he
said
he never did that facelift
well that's um that's what kind of sucks
is that I thought it was strange he even
mentioned that
you know he kind of made light of it but
but the thing is is that he was famous
for how good looking he was
and like I said I kind of feel like
maybe that is even shittier like once
you get him because you get old everyone
does like your looks are gonna change no
matter what you know surgery and [__]
can only do so much you know you can't
look like you're 20 your whole entire
life so it's like you're gonna look
older you can look good old right yeah
nobody's saying that you're that you
can't look good it's just that you're
not gonna look the same even women there
are women in their 60s that look great
you know old
because they've played it the right way
and they had work done but they don't
look young but they look good
yeah you can still look good at whatever
age you are it's just you're not gonna
look young you're not gonna look yeah no
and I kind of feel like like you said I
feel like his whole thing even though he
had other things going on like you can
sing he could write lyrics like he was a
good performer like he was charismatic
and stuff like that but I kind of feel
like he placed so much emphasis on his
looks because that's what
got him so much attention like to start
with like the way that he looked because
he was like super super hot like back in
the old day very very distinctive
looking yeah and so he based so much of
his identity around that that like when
he didn't look exactly like that anymore
like he started having problems yeah
like even though he was still putting
music out and all that other kind of
stuff and he could I think he was really
sensitive about it yeah he could have
he could have worked with what he had
um
you can use wigs if you want to have
hair but part of the problem was you
start to lose his hair
but he wanted to have long hair
or longish hair those two don't go
together you can't have hair when you
don't have hair
that's pretty deep
you're gonna have to make a choice
you're either gonna [__] shave your
hair off or you're gonna have to [__]
get to get your wig
um you can't have hair if you don't have
hair yeah
he uh that's a [__] professional
that's what this audience is here for
man because these little nuggets yeah of
wisdom yeah
and um he was Slender
not a physical guy they're skinny all
right but he looked good that he is yeah
he was like wise yeah his skeleton was
built for that kind of look and he had
those cheekbones right like those great
eyes he had those like really blue eyes
you know what I mean so um
when he started getting older he started
to get skinny fat
all right and he didn't look into the
[__] why that is you know what I mean
there was some he could have gone on
test and [__] that problem partly
would have gone away which is given a
little bit more resistance against the
drugs he was taken too okay he was he
was [__] test suppressed by bad
past 35 it starts to [__] dwindle and
by the time you're in your 40s and 50s
you just don't have enough Androgen
androgens in your system
to deal with [__] like drinking alcohol
[__] every night or every other night
and [__] running yourself to the Bone
every night on tour not getting any
sleep you know what I mean that's just
that's old men can't do that
and your body is starting to suffer so
he should have got into some performance
sports medicine that would have helped
him a lot and people said what are you
talking about he's not [__] no man rock
stars are athletes
that's a type of athleticism well it's a
it's a high uh energy lifestyle you're
performing man on stage and you got to
be able to [__] run around and dance
and jump around and look [__] and
then usually you have to travel to
another city to another city and then
you have to do it during the next night
right and it's usually like the hours
are because you're usually up all night
because you're traveling and then you
have to go to the next place and set up
and all that other kind of stuff so you
don't get a lot of sleep or anything
yeah now this was going on in the 90s
when he started to slide
late midnight late now I mean I saw him
after
deep came out
in 1990 and he looked fantastic like if
you've seen like the cuts you up video
he looked exactly like that and I was
like in the front row so I like saw him
from close up he looked exactly like
that he looked perfect like porcelain
skin and everything then I saw him in
95. yeah um I mean I saw him in 92 as
well but I think I saw him in 95 and he
still looked really good he was he had
his black hair back
um that was after holy smoke came out
and he still looks really good then I
saw him in 96 on that tour that he paid
for
um I think it was called Just For Love
or something like that was that 96 or 90
I don't remember and then I saw him
again when they did the Bauhaus tour in
and he still looks really good then but
I kind of feel like after that I think
that was the last time that I saw him
that he looked really really good like
after that it seemed like hit or miss
like sometimes he looked okay and
sometimes do you remember were you with
me that one time movie went and saw him
and it looked like he was wearing this
coat that kind of looked like a bathrobe
and yeah yeah
the
um
first time I saw him he looked real good
that was probably around 99 it was for
the Bauhaus tour wasn't that 99 I think
it was 98 98 or not yeah and he still
looked pretty good that was weird like
Gotham that's what that's yeah yeah I
saw the Gotham tour yeah I did too and
uh he stole it pretty good yeah he looks
good yeah look he looked like the old
Peter Murphy and then we saw more
recently in the past what five six years
I guess and he's
we've lost a lot of the audience people
have kind of checked out they don't
probably know what they're talking about
but uh yeah we're just talking about
goth rock stars
now I don't know what quote you want me
to put on probably the thing about the
hair oh is that it is okay because
that's what we're talking about yeah you
guys gonna understand I don't we don't
see in these comments until [__] a
long time after we've [__] said that
well sometimes so we don't have the
context a lot of times sometimes I try
to like keep track of what they are but
sometimes I can't like you know get to
them Zach says my favorite band ever is
a Finnish rock band called Poets of the
Fall I've heard of them but I don't
think I've ever heard anything of theirs
off to like look them up though
but yeah
um
I don't know like money thank you Jeffy
all right thank you very much
yeah you should totally put that on a
shirt
you don't you can't have Aaron too you
can't have hair if you don't have hair
yeah yeah
when was the last time when did we when
was the last time we saw Peter Murphy I
can't remember
I mean it must have been in the last
last time we saw 10 years or so yeah
last time we saw was at Firestone that's
right
yeah yeah that's not called Firestone
anymore is it we saw a lot of shows
there is a firestore and he's being a
[__]
he was yeah
you know who's good live man we uh I
think we've seen him at least once maybe
twice was um
um [__] Gary Newman Gary Newman yeah
yeah we saw Gary Newman Gary Newman's
very good live yeah he was awesome real
good he's real cool he's real [__]
friendly everybody loves him that was in
um
2012 2013 something like that yeah
that's like 10 years ago he has a
massive endurance and and I think it has
to do with he's got a good wife and he's
got he's really proud of his little
daughter her name's Raven I think yeah
and she uh she'll come up she's now
21 I think yeah it's funny how she grew
up so fast but she would do in the
little background vocals and [__]
[__] and would come up on stage and
[__] and she was just this pretty little
blonde goth girl his his I think his
wife and he said from one of his
interviews that he was able to continue
because it was a family business now
yeah and then it motivated him to
continue that's kind of awesome I really
really like yeah I really like that I
like when that whole I mean what
whatever it is whether you're like a
goth band or I really like
um you know people that are like horror
movies and stuff I really like when all
of the family are like into yeah that's
awesome his wife is cute man and she was
uh
um just a civilian girl
I think she's American that's civilian
just yeah no she wasn't in the industry
but she made a [__] um
a [__] Gary Newman fan club
and then got and then worked with him on
you know was able to get in contact with
him that she was head of Hispanic club
and she was like Mega fan form she was
she was his number one fan
he finally met her and they got married
but she ran the fan club for for every
daily years that's crazy because I kind
of feel like probably everybody that
starts a fan club like wishes that would
happen that's what happened
[Laughter]
yeah when you see her though she's
stunning well yeah because I kind of
feel like making sure that's not usually
the case so because she was so
interested in his career so supportive
of him it was so jacked about his
[__] material and [__] I think she
was kind of like his manager slightly
yeah I mean uh or at least the advisor
because uh he
he kind of went down some dead ends
especially in the late 80s you know with
his career started to try to do metal
music that didn't work out too well try
to do like almost Iggy pops and I didn't
he's good with industrial something more
along the lines of
Depeche Mode like a dark version of
Depeche Mode that's that's what he he
sounds good with that or something with
a with a hint of Nine Inch Nails
although I think he worked with Nine
Inch Nails he did yeah I think he he
produced I think some of that or
engineered it
it's funny we were talking I don't know
why this reminded me but um because you
mentioned Nine Inch Nails and then I was
like oh I was on my Spotify playlist it
I it played The Nine Inch Nails version
of The Joy Division song it's good yeah
and I was kind of like I like it but I
kind of wish they'd played the original
one because I like the original battle
obviously I had a I had a whole cover
tribute album I had a whole tribute
album to Dead Can Dance and it was goth
bands doing Dead Can Dance but it was
from the uh like 96. and it's gone now
my first wife gave me a copy of it
but I lost it you had a whole stack of
CDs in the closet at our old house yeah
it's not in that one I don't know it's
not in that oh it was I lost it a long
time I haven't seen it I don't know if
any of you guys know what it is I'm
talking about I'd like to find it again
although how hard could it be to find
that it was uh we'll see tribute album
from around 96 nowadays it'd be easy to
find that yeah you could find that you
could probably buy the [__] on iTunes
yeah probably yeah I mean I have I have
a tribute uh a Bauhaus tribute yeah
um that's pretty good uh I have a 11
Rockets tribute I have a 10th on tail
tribute yeah I have a whole bunch of
different ones I have a Bowie like a
goth Bowie tribute yeah
oh by the way that reminds me one of the
posters that I'm doing this weekend
is uh a band called Fame and they do
Bowie covers they're like I don't know
if it's um I have to look at the dates
because Mark just sent them to me but um
I don't know if it's if they're doing an
Orlando show or if it's just Tampa
because that's usually sometimes
sometimes bands will do like a Tampa and
then the next night they'll do like they
usually do Will's Pub
but American Military 100 says see he
likes a Haircut 100 he thought they were
very Innovative yeah they were good too
I like haircut yeah they were good they
had uh [__] uh what was it love plus
one remember that album yeah remember
that or that video that was good
everything I heard from them was good it
was kind of like uh
[__] what would be a good way to
describe that
it did have its own kind of sound didn't
it almost kind of sounded Caribbean
see I like a lot of that new weird stuff
so it's kind of like a Caribbean New
Wave sound
although I've never I don't think I've
ever heard a full album by them I don't
think I have either I think I've heard
three or four songs yeah I hear like
songs every year man but you know
I just I don't know like if I had to
pick a favorite genre like I really do
like a lot of that new wave stuff but I
mean I usually just say Post Punk
because that kind of encompasses
everything like all the weird [__] that
came out like after after Punk there was
another band that kind of reminded me of
the Smiths and I haven't heard any Smith
songs I've heard a lot of Morrissey
lately but I'd like to go back and
listen to some Smiths there was another
bed kind of like the Smiths that I
remember
from um I guess this must have been
around 80
7 86 it's called the house Martins yeah
yeah remember them yeah I like the house
I remember him as being like the Smiths
well there was a lot of bands because I
kind of feel like in the 80s like when
the Smiths first came out I mean their
first album came out what 84. yeah and
you know New Wave was then very kind of
like more electronic focused like more
synth focused so when the Smiths came
out it was kind of like this big just
like oh my God it's like a throwback to
like 60s 60s guitar rock yeah so it was
kind of a thing but people forget that
there was like a whole little mini scene
it wasn't just them it was like the
housewives I think it was like um uh who
are those other [__] uh doritic
column were they uh they were kind of
like that
um [__] man who was that other person I
remember was the house ones uh the
wooden tops I want to say I don't know
there was like some other bands like
that that were kind of smithsy did all
canvas so there was like because anytime
you have the some big thing where it's
like oh everything's synth heavy you're
gonna have like like a little bit of a
backlash look at Pokey folks coming to
visit on the show yeah yeah you make an
End appearance yeah yeah she always
looks like so
oh look at you pokey yeah look at you
pookie look at her little face
[Laughter]
I said I've ever known they'll like just
let you stick your face in her face yeah
and she's just like whatever yeah she'll
lean into it yeah she's like okay if you
pretend to lick on her head I'll pretend
to lick on her head she'll lean into it
she's actually being kind of chill she's
sat on your lap for a long time she
doesn't usually do that yeah I got her
relaxed yeah oh poke yeah you have
you haven't been going for Jim
hour and 54 minutes yeah it's about time
Tammy says Pookie yeah yeah
American Military 100 said Haircut 100
it's Pelican West was their only album
okay caribbean-esque Post Punk and
Brazilian percussion okay yeah yeah so I
remember calling it yeah
okay
um I guess we're getting kind of tired
huh yeah
she's been working all day yeah and I I
woke up at
um quarter to five
yeah I think it was quarter five so
we've talked you into this coming
weekend and chilled you out
sit here drinking drinks with you
talking about music from the old days
pet and Pokey petting Pokey griping
about
griping about Peter Murphy
yeah what's up book opinions
look at a little faith yeah
oh yeah being cute huh you are so cute
Pokey yeah look at your little look at
your little feet yeah
look at your little feets yeah she's
like yep that's my feet yeah
all right so
uh tomorrow we're gonna take that I'm
gonna get some [__] sleep yeah and
Sunday we'll do a movie review we'll do
one of the movies that Louie sent us
okay yeah oh no you want to do
Highlander didn't you I mean it doesn't
matter okay we can do either one okay uh
Jeff yard said has a new job going by
the way oh it's pretty good pretty good
you know she's making money it's a job
making money
um it's more like the the commute's a
[__] but you know other than that like
it's it's fine like I said it's at least
I'm getting some bills paid so that's
kind of nice
all right so we'll either do Black Hawk
Down or
like we can watch that because we're not
going out tomorrow night either right
because we like I said we got to go out
I don't think two nights yeah next week
so I don't know we'll see how we feel
tomorrow night
because you know I mean we can kind of
afford one we can afford to go out
probably
just depends on how we feel yeah
and honestly if we go to mannequins I
always like Friday nights at mannequins
better yeah like if Saturdays I kind of
like Barbara Elementary
you know what I mean yeah but I mean
mannequins is fun on Saturday too but
it's a little bit weird like the music's
kind of all over the place yeah which
you know sometimes that's good and
sometimes not so much but you know what
I mean uh all right so thank you
everybody for hanging out with us thanks
for super chats and we'll be back on
Sunday doing a movie review probably
doing it probably uh 6 p.m Eastern
Standard Time
but I'll probably announce it or
whatever but uh yeah so have a good day
tomorrow everybody have a good rest of
your evening and we'll see you guys
again on Sunday good night